here i go oh my lord i know it's hot in
mexico henry your book is number one
what in the official mexican fiction
chart i mean i don't speak a word of
spanish oh
thank you
i translate for you i'm the translator
of your book
you're ms rodriguez
okay okay
we better hurry we've got 30 minutes to
get to your event my what sorry
[Music]
why are all these people here
i made some changes
[Music]
what have you done to my book
i made it more interesting
is
sounds like you've rewritten the whole
book
[Music]
only the boring parts
this book is a hit
so tell people what they want to hear
work together and get into the car
you should see the one we rejected
hey
you have an easy life
i clean and i work in a bar
all i ever wanted to do is write no way
henry copper welcome
love is an ideal whether it's a man and
a woman yes or a woman and a woman
page 92
indeed
you know i could tell you don't know
anything about life how did you know
that i read your book
you've never been in love
everyone seems to like your ideas better
than mine so tell me
what's it about the novellas
[Music]
[Music]
now i need you to translate something
for me
[Music]